in the last video we showed you the
kaushi swartz inequality kaoshi
shorts
schwartz inequality
inequality and i think it's worth
rewriting because this is something
that's going to show up a lot it's a
very useful tool and that just told us
if i have two vectors
x
and
y
they're both
members of rn and they're both
non-zero non-zero vectors and that was
an assumption we had to make when we did
the proof otherwise we there was a
potential of dividing by one of their
magnitudes so that would have been been
a big no-no but if that we assume that
they're both non-zero then we can say
that the absolute value
the absolute value of their dot products
is going to be less than or equal to
the products of their individual length
so that's the length of vector x and we
defined that a couple of videos ago and
then this is the length of vector y and
of course this is just a regular number
and then each of these are just regular
numbers they're not vectors once you
take a length this the length of a 50
dimensional vector could just be the
number three it's just a scalar value so
this this is this is just scalar
multiplication here and we also learned
that the only time that this inequality
turns into an equality is the situation
where x
where x is equal to some scalar multiple
of y and so in some textbooks you'll say
and this has to be a non-zero scalar
multiple but that's a bit obvious i told
you that x and y are non-zero so if this
was zero then
x would be zero and that we i just said
that x is non-zero but if you want to
say there you could say that you know c
also is going to be non-zero
non-zero but that essentially just falls
out of this information there but if
this is the case and if and only if this
is the case
then we can say that the absolute value
of the dot product of the two vectors is
equal to
the product
of their lengths
now this is all just a review of what i
did in the last video now what what else
can we do that's useful with it so let's
just play around a little bit but well i
can't claim to be experimenting i know
where this is going to go
let's see what happens if i were to take
if i were to take the length
if i were to take the length of
x
plus y so i'm going to add the two
vectors and then take the length of that
vector squared
well we know from a couple of videos ago
that the length squared can also be
rewritten
as the dot product of a vector with
itself
this right here x plus y i know it looks
like two vectors but it's two vectors
added to each other so it's really a
vector x plus y is a real vector i could
graph x plus y
so the length of x plus y squared i can
rewrite it as the dot product
of that vector with itself so x plus y
dot
x plus y and all of these are vectors
these aren't just numbers and this is
the dot product it's just not normal
multiplication but we saw two videos ago
that the dot product
has the distributive and the associative
and the commutative properties just like
regular scalar multiplication so you can
kind of foil this out if you if that's
how you remember
multiplying your binomials or i always
think of it more as just doing the
distributive property twice so this can
be rewritten as
this can be rewritten as x dot x
actually let me write it as a
distributive property because that's
sometimes not obvious to a lot of people
so let me write this x as a yellow x
and write and let me write this this
whole term is x plus y
so this right here can be rewritten as
x
dot
so this x dot
this x plus y
and then it would be plus this y
dot
i wanted to switch colors
plus
this y
dot
x plus y it's good to see that when
you're multiplying these you're just
applying the distributive property
right all i did is i distributed this
term along each of these terms in this
sum right here so then i got this and
then i can distribute each of these into
the sum so then this becomes
i'll be careful with the colors x
dot
x dot x
plus
x dot y i just maybe this was a little
bit overkill but i think it's good to
see that this isn't just some magic here
and we're just using the exact
properties that we proved the dot
product so that's that right there and
then it's plus
plus
y dot x so y
dot x y dot x
plus
this yellow y
yellow y
dot the yellow x
not the yellow
sorry dot the blue y
not the blue eye so the magnitude or the
length of our vector x plus y squared
can be rewritten like this
and this and i'll just switch back to
one color
so this equals that
and all of that
what does this equal this is equal to
x dot x
so this is equal to what's x dot x x dot
x is just the magnitude so let me write
this is just equal to the magnitude of
our
vector
x
i should stop using the word magnitude
the length of our vector x
squared
and then i have
two terms here i have an x dot y and a y
dot x but we know that x dot y and y dot
x are really the the same thing we show
that that you can order doesn't matter
when you take the dot product just like
it doesn't matter with regular
multiplication so these are really the
same term so we could write plus
2 times x
2 times x dot y
and then finally we have that last term
sitting here we have this y dot y y dot
y is the same thing as the length
of our vector y
the length
squared
now let's see if we can break out our
kaishi schwartz inequality
or maybe schwarz i don't know if i'm
pronouncing it right
but x dot y so x dot y we have the
absolute value of x dot y here right but
we know that the the
just x dot y
x dot y is going to be it has to be less
than or equal to the absolute value of x
dot y
let me
uh x
dot y why is that well this could be
negative i could show you examples of
dot products that are negative in fact
if x has all positive terms and and
y has all negative terms you're going to
have a a negative dot product so this
could be negative or it could be
positive it's positive the absolute
value they're equal to each other if
this is negative then this absolute
value is definitely going to be greater
than it so we can even we can add to the
kaushi swartz inequality and this is a
bit obvious we could say look
we could add a little
we could add a little x
dot y is less than or equal to the
absolute value of x dot y which is abs
less than or equal to the mag the length
of x times the length of y
so x dot y is def this
the length of x dot or the dot product
of x with y is definitely less than its
absolute value of that which is
definitely less than the lengths of
those two multiplied
so if i rewrite this this
this statement right here is definitely
less than or equal to so this is
definitely
less than or equal to this exact
statement but if i replace these with
the lengths of the vectors
so that is definitely less than or equal
to
i'm just rewriting this x squared and
i'll write the
i'll write the plus 2 there
plus 2 but i want to make it very clear
what i'm replacing here
and then i have the plus
length of my vector y there squared now
this i'm saying this is definitely less
than the absolute value of x dot y which
is definitely less by the kaushi
schwartz inequality
definitely less than the than the
product of the two lengths
so all i did here so i'm just replacing
this with the product of their two
lengths
so i'm going to put
x
the length of x times
the length
of y right and since this is the same as
that this is the same as that but this
is definitely less than this this whole
term has to be less than this whole term
now let me just remind you what we were
doing
i said that this thing this thing that i
wrote over here this is the same as that
so this thing up here which is the same
as that which is less than that also so
we can write that the magnitude of x
plus
y squared and not the magnitude the
length of the vector x plus y squared is
less than this whole thing that i wrote
out here
now or less than or equal to now what is
this thing remember i mean this might
look all fancy with the my little double
lines around everything but these are
just numbers this mag this length of x
squared this is just a number each of
these are numbers and i can just say hey
look this looks like a perfect square to
me
this looks just like
this term on the right hand side is the
exact same thing as
the length of x
plus the length of y
everything
everything squared right if you just
square this out you'll get x squared
plus 2 times the length of x times the
length of y plus y squared so our
length of the vector x plus y
the length of our vector x plus y
squared is less than or equal to this
quantity over here and if we just take
the square root of both sides of this
you get
the length of our vector x plus y
is less than or equal to
the length
of the vector x by itself
plus
the length of the vector y
and we call this the triangle inequality
which you might have remembered from
geometry triangle inequality
triangle inequality now why is it called
a triangle inequality well you can
imagine each of these to be separate
sides of a triangle in fact let's draw
it we can draw this in r2 let me turn my
my graph paper on
let me let me see where the graphs show
up
if i turn my graph paper on
right there maybe i'll draw it here so
let's draw my vector x
so let's say that my vector x looks
something like
this
let's say that's my vector x it's the
vector 2 4
so that's my vector x
and let's say my vector y well i'm just
going to do it i'm just going to do it
heads to tail because i'm going to add
the two
so my vector y i'm going to do the
non-standard position let's say it looks
something like
oh let's say my vector y looks something
like this
i'm going to draw it properly
so that's let's say that that's my
vector y
so that's my vector y then what does x
plus y look like
x plus y and remember i'm just
i can't necessarily draw any two vectors
on two-dimensional space like this i'm
just assuming that these are an r two
but this is just to give you the idea
so then um
so then this is their sum right you talk
from the tail of x to the head of y
so this vector right here
is the vector
x plus y and that's why it's called a
triangle inequality it's just saying
that look
this thing is always going to be less
than or equal to or the length of this
thing
the length of this thing is always going
to be less than or equal to the length
of this thing plus the length of this
thing and that's kind of obvious when
you just learn two-dimensional geometry
that look this is this is a much more
efficient way of getting from this point
to this point than going out here and
then going out here and then what's the
limiting or what's the case in which
this length is equal to these lengths
well if you keep flattening this
triangle out and you go to the extreme
case
you go to the extreme case where maybe
the vector x looks like this
the vector x looks like this and if the
vector
y
is just kind of going in the exact same
let me vector y is going in the exact
same direction maybe it's going a little
bit further
right
so that is
this is vector x
this is vector y now x plus y will just
be this whole vector
now that whole thing is x plus y and
this is the case now where you actually
where the where the triangle inequality
turns into an equality that's why the
little equal sign there the extreme case
where essentially x and y are collinear
and why does that work out we can even
go back to our math and understand that
so let me turn my graph off we can go
back to our math here
if i go to back to this point remember
right here i made the statement look
this thing is definitely less than this
thing over here but what if i made an
assumption
what if i said
what if i said that
x
is equal to sum scalar times y
and actually i have to be careful
because just some scalar times y
remember our our our our kaushi schwartz
inequality
said that look
the the inequality turns into an
equality if x is some non-zero scalar of
y and then we can apply this we can say
that the absolute value of x dot y is
the same as this over here but i don't
have the absolute value of x dot y here
i don't know that this is positive i can
say definitively that this is a positive
quantity because i took the absolute
value of it no absolute value here so
the only way that i can ensure that this
is a positive quantity that this is the
same thing as the absolute value of x
dot y
is to enforce if i'm kind of going to go
down this road is to enforce this term
right here that c be positive
because if c is positive then
x
dot y
if x dot y
then that would be the same thing as
c
y
dot
y which we know is just the same thing
as c times the magnitude of y squared
and the only way that i can ensure that
this expression right here is equal to
the absolute value of x
dot y
the only way i can assure this is if c
is positive if c is negative then this
is going to then this is going to be a
negative number while this is a positive
so if i assume that this is positive if
i assume that this is positive then i
can say that x dot y
x dot y is equal to the magnitude is
equal to the absolute value of x dot y
and since it's a scalar multiple then i
could say that that term is equal to is
equal to not just less than or equal to
the magnitude of x's and y's
so hopefully i'm not confusing you so
all i'm saying is if i can assume that x
is some positive scalar multiple of y
that this wouldn't be a less than sign
then i could say that x dot y is the
same thing as the absolute value of x
dot y since this is positive and if it's
the same thing as the absolute value of
x dot y
and it's some scale or multiple of each
other then we could go down this other
route we could say that this thing here
i don't want to get too messy we could
say that this is equal to that if this
is equal to that then this would have
become an equal sign not a less than or
equal to sign and then we would have had
the limiting case
we would have the limiting i don't call
the limiting case but we could say that
x plus y
we've done the same work but we'd have
an equal sign the whole way would equal
the length of x the length of x plus y
would equal the length of x plus the
length of y
in the situation where x is equal to
some positive scalar times y so c
is greater than
zero if we can these two imply each
other and we saw that geometrically
i don't i lost my axis here but we see
that the only time that x the max the
length of x plus y is equal to the
length of x plus the length of y is when
they're collinear right over here this
plus this is clearly you can just
visually look at it longer than this
right there so you might be saying sal
once again you know this linear algebra
is a little bit silly we learned the
triangle inequality in eighth or ninth
grade you know why did you go through
all of this pain to redefine it and this
is the interesting thing what i just
drew here and what this is what you
learned in this is what you learned in
9th grade geometry this is just this is
just an r2 this is just you know your
cartesian coordinates or i don't want to
use the word dimension too much because
we're going to define that formally but
this is kind of your two-dimensional
space that's going on but i what's
interesting or what's what's useful
about linear algebra is we've just
defined the triangle inequality for an
arbitrarily
large
vectors or or vectors that have an
arbitrarily high number of components
each of these these don't have to these
don't have to be an r2 these could be
this could be this is true if we're in r
r 100 where every vector has a hundred
components to it we've just defined some
notion of the triangle inequality we've
abstracted well beyond just our two
dimensional cartesian coordinates well
beyond even our three dimensions to
essentially n dimensional space and i
haven't defined dimensions yet but i
think you're starting to appreciate what
they are but anyway hopefully that you
found that useful and we'll now we can
now take this result
we can now take this result and actually
that result with this result and define
what the notion of an angle between two
vectors are and once again this is very
this is you know on some levels you're
like wow why do we have to define an
angle isn't an angle just you know isn't
isn't that just an angle well yeah we
know what an angle is in two dimensions
but what does an angle mean when you
abstract things to n dimensions or when
you when you're in r n so that's what
we'll talk about in the next video